five four three two one go gorilla do
you like cake I love cake do you like
fruits yeah for snapping it wonders grab
the bun like fruit have you heard of a
fruit cake before no what do you think
they're made out of are you excited to
try them I'm very excited know why
because it might have crickets what does
it look like to you a big mole it smells
like a very pancake and strawberry oh no
I'm gonna try not to get the free well
solve in this makes my belly feel super
happy
this is the same thing yes I hope it's
not like cinnamon of course I do look
like brownie with like apples in that
piece Oh God
[Music]
tasting mmm not too bad
[Music]
it's that good no looks like bananas or
peach that doesn't sound so good do you
like pineapple sometimes but sometimes
they're just too sour it reminds me of
being at a party
the flowers gross but I bet I like it
hmmm
[Music]
well it tastes like all right anything
little I would love to are they were
delicious
I like the apple cinnamon one I love the
pineapple fruit cake
then I would sell bad No won't to eat
more of anything
hi my mom would bake goodbye grandma
because she's that kind of person
what kind of person is she old
[Music]